this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today Liz and I are talking with
Aaron sibarium a staff writer at the
Washington Free Beacon whose work has
been widely and correctly credited with
exposing the apparent plagiarism of
former Harvard president claan gay gay
announced her resignation on January 2nd
a day after sibarium published six new
plagiarism charges some of which will
detail soon as we explore the story its
implications for the ivy league and for
diversity equity incl and inclusion or
Dei and also for writers and thinkers of
all kinds who can now have their work
subjected to high powerered maybe even
AI powerered plagiarism detection Aaron
sarum thank you for talking with us
thank you so much for having me let's
start uh by looking at some of the
specific examples of uh Claudine Gay's
apparent plagiarism this is from that
article that January 1 article I
mentioned um where you put side by side
some of her writing next to a scholar
named David Cannon and uh we can see by
the highlighted material here I'll just
for our audio listeners I'll just read
that first highlighted paragraph David's
Canon version is uh the V is often cited
as one of the most significant pieces of
civil rights legislation passed in our
nation's history Claudine gay writes the
Voting Rights Act of 1965 is often cited
as one of the most significant pieces of
civil rights legislation passed in our
nation's history then it goes down on to
describe the central parts of uh this uh
of the Voting Rights Act and it's almost
identical language um one other example
I'll pull up here Claudine gay and Gary
King side by side Gary King writes the
posterior distribution of each of the
precinct parameters within the bounds
indicated by its tomography line is
drived by the slice that cuts out of the
bate uh bivariate distribution Claudine
gay writes the posterior distribution of
each of the precinct parameters for
Precinct is derived by the slice its
graphy line cuts out of this byari
distribution so these are fairly
technical descriptions of uh kind of
political um political districting and
so forth and
legislation and my understanding is that
she uh did not even you know often
people will put in parenthesis I'm
citing this person or footnote or
endnote she didn't put any of that but
she did cite these people in their
bibliography
so what um you know what should we take
away from these the these are just a few
select examples but of the the many
examples that you have compiled of
plagiarism in her
work well it's a Continuum of severity
right and even your own examples I think
show that um the more technical example
that you mentioned with the B variant
distribution um
that's not ideal but I think she could
plausibly say that that was at worst
mildly sloppy and at best kosher because
her argument and the argument some other
social scientists have made is that at
when you're describing very technical
methods or even describing the terms in
an equation which is not quite what
she's doing there but it's close uh
there's only so many ways to to describe
an equation or describe a very technical
model in social science so it's hard to
avoid redundancy it would be unrealistic
to
site every single time there's some
redundant technical verbiage um you know
that is a common argument people have
made it's not an argument that is
incorporated into
Harvard's uh plagiarism policies for
students those policies don't make any
kind of exception for technical language
but if you're looking at this relative
to the Norms of social science
scholarship ah I think you could defend
some of those examples um the one that
you put on the screen with David Cannon
I think is harder to defend because it's
not technical language it's also uh much
more extensive right it's several par
it's several sentences um which if you
actually look on the page of her book
that that's from comprise almost half of
the half a page of material um it's
stuff that yes there maybe aren't that
many ways to word the technical ins and
outs of the Voting Rights Act but still
there's so so many of those sentences
are just copy pasted it's pretty hard to
argue that she couldn't have
changed at least a few more words uh or
or or moved some things around that I
think is more you know again taken in
isolation is at the end of the world no
but it's it's a more severe case
relatively and then the most severe case
that uh I don't think you put on the
board but is worth mentioning um it's
from a previous article I wrote is when
she
copied um pretty much an entire
paragraph uh verbatim from uh two of her
colleagues in the Harvard government
Department um Bradley Palmquist and
Steph Voss without not only without uh
quotation marks or without citing them
in parenthesis but without listing them
in her bibliography anywhere so that was
a pretty clear-cut case that one of just
straight up plagiarism that I don't
think anyone could really defend or
argue with anything other than
plagiarism and in fact that that is one
of the passages that she uh corrected um
uh she she added quotation marks in a
citation after being called on it um so
there's really a spectrum here um but
there's a lot of examples that fall on
various parts of the spectrum so even if
you think that maybe 25 even 30 40 of
the examples are minor there's still 40
of those examples plus maybe six to 10
more severe ones and you're looking at a
pattern how egregious do you think this
would be in
Academia if gay hadn't been in her role
as president of Harvard if she were just
an academic and the Scandal came out and
it wasn't colored with all of these um
sort of political under and overtones
how do you think academics would treat
her well we have some Clues based on how
Harvard has treated former cases like
this from just regular professors um and
what they've typically done is either
not punished them or has said yes they
plagiarized but it wasn't that big a
deal so we're not going to punish them
at all right where the to the extent
there was a punishment it's merely the
sort of official determination that
plagiarism took place but there's no Act
ual uh you know material
sanction like being censured in Congress
right like that doesn't actually much
it's a symbolic slap on the wrist right
so that happened to Larry tribe and I
think a couple other professors over the
past two decades um it's Alan dtz Larry
tribe there's one other law professor
and then uh Jill Abramson same thing
happened and in all of these cases the
professors
basically apologized and in a couple
cases the university saide they did
technically
plagiarize you know that's unfortunate
but they didn't really do anything about
it um so if she were just a tene faculty
member the normal response would be for
her to
forthrightly say yep maypa screwed up
sorry and then the university did not
really do anything um of course a as you
say she's not a normal 10y faculty she's
the president of the entire University
and B she did not do what those other
professors did which was to own up to
their mistakes and for everyone to just
acknowledge yeah it was plagiarism but
you know not the end of the world uh
instead she and the Harvard corporation
uh retained a really high-powered Law
Firm Clare lock to try to suppress the
story with a defamation threat to the
New York Post um you know employing
these really Cloak and Dagger tactics to
just prevent it from ever coming to
light uh uh and then after we published
the story you know and and it became
hard for them to ignore they say well it
wasn't plagiarism it was just inadequate
citation or duplicative
language uh blah blah blah blah blah
euphemism
Galore and and and in the course of
investigating the allegations the
university did launch its own probe they
did not go through the normal processes
uh out by the research misconduct office
they just basically appointed these
unnamed political scientists to do this
very not opaque non-transparent
investigation totally outside of the
norms and processes Harvard has laid out
to do this kind of
probe so when you look at the response
in some ways the cover up is worse than
the crime um they really I there's never
been another professor in Harvard's
history where they've employed anything
like these tactics to try to suppress
the story um or then to downplay it when
it could no longer be suppressed and I
think that you know that that is a real
difference right my and my understanding
is uh correct me if I'm wrong she is
still employed at Harvard and drawing a
significant salary even though she resed
$900,000 a year or something seem like
that and that's not even counting the
speaking fees that one can draw later on
right like that's not even the once the
yeah once the example piled up uh you
know she resigned the presidency but uh
not exactly taking a huge hit
financially there there there's one more
example that was the
most kind of uh amusing and alarming one
to me which was documented in the New
York Times uh where she copied the
acknowledgments from yes a uh of in her
1997 Harvard dissertation she uh copied
the acknowledgments from a another one
one of her Harvard colleagues of
political science Jennifer a hosch child
wrote uh Sally jenx showed me the
importance of getting the data right and
following where they lead without fear
or favor adding later that M Mr jenx
drove me much harder than I sometimes
wanted to be driven sorry that was Sandy
Janks and then uh do Dr Gay uh thanked
her thesis adviser who reminded me of
the importance of getting the data right
and following where they lead without
fear or favor and then thanked her
family who drove me harder than I
sometimes wanted to be
driven I mean what do you do you have
like a theory of mind for what is going
on here is this just like she's
producing so much content that it's just
like she's grabbing from wherever she
can to put these manuscripts together
like what do you have any insight as to
what's going on
here yeah I mean maybe she just felt
like she needed to have an
acknowledgement section but was crunched
for time before
filing for dissertation um yeah and was
cribbing in the way He suggests I have
to say you know it that example on one
level is more minor because it doesn't
involve plagiarizing any kind of
substantive scholarly language certainly
doesn't involve plagiarizing an idea but
on the other hand it does seem to be the
example that
has Disturbed the largest number of
people including I think members of the
Harvard faculty you know I I can't name
names but I I I've been told by multiple
professors at Harvard that
that particular example
really bothered them um because it just
seemed so gratuitous so hard to
rationalize right you know the
acknowledgements are supposed to be
these deep personalized heartfelt
expressions of gratitude and here you
are cribbing a stock phrase from
somebody else it just really rubbed
people the wrong way so so even folks I
think who were inclined to dismiss some
of the allegations as either politically
motivated or simply not that big a deal
just seem to think that this one
indicated
something NE negative about her
character I think the best you can say
is that she was rather lazy um and the
worst you can say is that maybe there
was a kind of almost pathological
inability to come up with original
language um even to thank your own
mentors
um and yeah you know I I don't I don't
think that that single
example would have made all the
difference but I it is interesting to
run the counterfactuals right in which
you subtract this or that given example
and that does seem to be one of the
examples that really moved the needle
for quite a few people um so yeah it's
possible that without that simple
copying uh that one instance of copying
maybe she survives this probably not but
uh that one really seemed to upset
people in in my conversations in a way
that a lot of the other ones did
not I want I want to take us back to a
key point in this drama that maybe will
help us expand the lens a little bit
which is December 5th when Claud and gay
appeared in front of Congress alongside
upen president Elizabeth McGill who also
resigned her post shortly after this
appearance uh and mit's president Sally
cornbluth they were being grilled by
Congress member Elise stefanic a
republican from New York um about what
unfolded on their campuses after the
Hamas attack on Israel let's watch that
and then
comment M Migel at Penn does calling for
the genocide of Jews violate Penn's
rules or code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
pervasive it is harassment so the answer
is yes it is a context dependent
decision Congress woman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
McGill so is your testimony that you
will not answer yes if it uh is if the
speech becomes if the speech becomes
conduct it can be harassment yes conduct
meaning committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss mcel I'm going
to give you one more opportunity for the
world to see your answer does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate Penn's
code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes and Dr Gay at Harvard does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate Harvard
rules of bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be depending on the context
what's the context targeted as an
individual targeted as at an individual
it's targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals do you understand your
testimony is dehumanizing them do you
understand that dehumanization is part
of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no anti-semitic
rhetoric when anti-semitic rhetoric
anti-semitic rhetoric when it crosses
into conduct that amounts to bullying
harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
correct again
it depends on the context it does not
depend on the context the answer is yes
and this is why you should resign these
are unacceptable answers across the
board I think it's fair to say that this
is what got the snowball rolling
downhill on the plagiarism investigation
right yeah I think it's safe to say that
she was under extraordinary scrutiny um
in the wake of that testimony although
if you look at the
Timeline the New York Post actually
contacted Harvard about some of the
initial allegations all the way back in
late October so the impetus for that
presumably I mean it couldn't have been
her testimony because happen yet it was
probably just her kind of uh flailing
around trying to respond to
the the initial October 7th attacks and
making a number of statements that um
alums and students were insufficient
making them too late making them with uh
insufficiently with insufficient moral
Clarity one might say um so you know I
think it is safe to say that the the the
broader controversy over anti-Semitism
that ignited in the wake of October 7th
uh did greatly increase scrutiny on gay
including her AC GRS when actually
examining the statements that the
college President presidents gave to
Alise stonic like are they wrong I think
all of us react in a prickly manner to
the double standards of speech on these
Hyper Elite college campuses but when I
actually sort of remove it from the
context of the situation in which they
clearly you know really failed to
respond with any sort of
um moral Clarity and emotional resonance
but when I actually examine the things
that they are saying like I think I
agree by and large with what these
presidents are saying that you know we
should basically have uh an incredibly
high standard must be reached and
specific conditions must be met before
um you know speech is cracked down on on
a college campus how did you feel when
reacting to the testimonies initially
Aaron basically the same way you did um
I I thought that their answers on the
merits
were correct and in fact I don't
even I I I can't say I love this game of
saying well but they should have been
more empathetic you know I don't I've
spent a lot of my admittedly short
professional career
uh implicitly fighting against the the
people who invoke empathy as a
justification for shutting down speech I
I think the whole idea that students
feelings
are here is kind of wrong like like
they're not relevant to the question of
whether speech should be protected and
frankly I think Camp college campuses
would be a better place
all organized kind
of identity groups Jews
African-Americans gays Etc if all of
them just if there wasn't this sense
that the their grievances
like carried as much weight and and were
allowed to sort of dictate University
policy it's not to say that there you
know any group's feelings don't matter
in a moral sense of course not but the
idea that bureaucrats should be trying
to kind of micromanage ethnic or or
religious or cultural tensions on campus
I just think is a fundament rest on a
fundamentally mistaken conception of
what the university is or what it's for
um so look in my ideal world you
know none of these questions would have
been asked at the hearing because we
wouldn't even have this regime of kind
of not just Dei but anti-harassment law
that
basically you know in effect
allows people to argue well you know if
there have been a lot of
microaggressions then the conduct is
severe pervasive enough that the
university has to start policeing the
microaggressions no no no I I I think
that whole way of thinking about it is
wrong and antithetical to the mission of
the
University however as you also know it
it's hard for me to come to their
defense here when the same people
invoking free speech against uh
stefanic uh have spent the past decade
trampling on all sorts of speech that uh
this or that other group uh besides Jews
uh doesn't like right uh Harvard gay was
personally involved in removing uh from
Sullivan from an administrative post
because he served on Harvey Weinstein's
defense team she was involved in
sanctioning the star black Economist
Roland frier ostensively for sexual
harassment but a lot of people think it
was pretty clearly a pretext over his
his scholarship which had found some
sort of Politically Incorrect results
about the police and and used the force
against black people uh you know and and
there was some there were controversies
over Carol hooven who said There only
two Sexes which started a firestorm
there have been all sorts of cases like
this at Harvard where the Administration
has consistently at best sort of just
you know allowed departments and
students and faculty members to to
effectively engage in cancel culture
with no no even minor rebuke from the
administration saying hey we don't
really think that you guys should cancel
the talk um that's at best and at worst
the Administration has actively sought
to press descenting viewpoints so you
know as much as I would love uh to to
issue this kind of stentorian defens of
free speech and to say oh actually Claud
and gay was right I mean I just she
doesn't deserve people coming to her Aid
like that considering all of the times
that she suppressed conservative speech
as the dean of the faculty of Arts and
Sciences so there's no world in which
the Overton Windows should be so narrow
that Carol hooven or Roland frier are
sort of seen as far outside of it right
like there's no world in which uh an
elite college campus ostensibly for the
purpose of uh learning and you know
intellectual debate should be
considering Carol Hoin too far outside
of the realm of reasonable right like
that's just to me shows that horribly
wrong and and of course I think it's
worth adding that although I think
students should be free to endorse Hamas
without sanction from the universities
maybe from their future employers is a
different story but from the University
itself sure they they should be allowed
to do that um that is a much much more
extreme crazy out there view than there
are only two Sexes and this is something
that sometimes gets lost like we have to
remember that the substance of the views
here even if they should all be
protected is not the same and I think
most reasonable people would a agree
that the things Carol Huen got canceled
saying
are much more rationally defensible than
oh yeah October 7th was just an act of
Palestinian resistance that was great
right like the second thing is a lot
crazier than the first thing we're
talking about like the scientific fact
of like you know fast twitched and slow
twitched muscle fibers versus like the
terrorists who kind of did burn a bunch
of bodies and a big Massacre of
civilians like these two things are kind
of not on the same level at all I I I
really um take your point very well and
I think that that is something that so
frequently gets lost yeah I and I mean I
I agree with you that it's extremely
hard to swallow The Selective uh defense
of free speech uh however I I still am
concerned when there is a def no matter
how hypocritical if there is a defense
of free speech for there if if part of
the campaign to take down these
president is because they
are not uh embracing the regime of
microaggressions in this particular
instance that that is a little
disturbing to me and I mean a lot of and
I'm not putting any of this on you your
reporting is completely legitimate but I
know that the way that a lot of this was
kicked off you know you you posted the
document that was submitted to the Free
Beacon from from an anonymous Professor
uh from a different University uh that
had a a bunch of the initial plagiarism
allegations in it and obviously not
going to ask you to reveal who that
source is um but do you have any insight
about the motivations in that specific
instance or can speak to kind of the
motivations to Beyond just concern for
plagiarism and academic Integrity in
sure bringing down Claudine
gay sure well I I think it obviously is
the case that uh
people people probably would not have
started
digging as intensely as they did had it
not been for her statements now now what
it was about her statements that upset
people I can't really speculate about
particular individuals motivations but I
would just say that I do know a lot of
people who agree with you
that free speech is important and the
answers they gave were legally correct
but also think that the answers betrayed
such an absurd institutional
hypocrisy that that that itself should
have been disqualifying that the the
hypocrisy really was just just you know
astonishing and upsetting so to the
extent people searching for plagiarism
were motivated by her testimony you know
I do think it's important to recognize
that they could well have been motivated
not by a sense that oh my God she won't
Embrace Dei protections for Jews she has
to go it could well have been they
thought look you know she's just a kind
of a terrible career administrator who's
been complicit in the silencing of all
sorts of conservative views and now she
has the hpah to get up there and say oh
now that it comes to calling for the
genocide of Jews Free Speech you know
screw this lady I mean I think that
actually was a pretty common
reaction um it's unfortunately not quite
the sentiment that Alise stefanic
articulated at the hearing but among the
kind of broader masses of you know
disgruntled academics I actually do
think that that sentiment was pretty
pretty prevalent um I would say this
though too about just my own motivations
in reporting I I do think that the
plagiarism you know serial plagiarism
from the president of Harvard University
is obvious a
story regardless of whether any of this
anti-Semitism had happened and I
actually think it speaks to a kind of
failure of of liberals to pass the
ideological Turing test that they think
that we only went after you know like oh
you you only wanted to go after claudian
gay because she's black or because of
the anti-Semitism thing no no no no no
conservatives have long thought that
these institutions are terrible for all
sorts of reasons totally aside from
anti-Semitism and the idea that
conservatives I'm not even speaking
about my own motivations here per se but
like like the idea that conservatives
wouldn't jump to you know kind of hurt
any ivy league president for just about
any reason given um how they see the IV
league and its role in American society
it's like you you you clearly the the
the critics of the sort of so-called you
know conservative cancel culture
whatever they they just don't understand
uh the depth of the critique of the
universities on the right um they have
no concept of How Deeply
compromised and corrupt conservatives
take the university to be and as such
have no
conception really of why it is
conservatives would
welcome plagiarism allegations against
basically any Elite College president
except maybe for the Pres of you Chicago
but other than him like you know uh like
like like I mean if someone I I joked
about this on a few things where people
ask me like oh did you do this because
you went to Yale and she's at Harvard
I'm like guys that that's cute but no
like if believe me if you have if you
have uh if you know about plagiarism in
the president of yalees work or the
president of Princeton like please send
it to me like of course I would publish
that you know um well are the
institutions
terrible right like you brought that up
as like something in the conservative
imagination but like is it true do you
believe it what do you
think yeah more or less now I mean we
can in a minute get to the whole
question
of whether sort of we want to be
systematic hunts for plagiarism in the
work of every academic I think there are
interesting debates about whether that
would really be good or whether that
that might you know create some bad bad
Norms what have you
um but as to my own views on the
University look I think that the thread
connecting the plagiarism Scandal to the
anti-Semitism Scandal is this
notion of double standards right there
was one standard for claing gay
plagiarism uh which university said oh
that wasn't misconduct it's fine and a
much stricter standard for students who
uh were upset when they heard about the
story because they said wait a minute we
would get kicked out if we did B Wad and
G did and by the same token right the
thing about
anti-Semitism that I think really did g
a lot of people was the double standard
oh you you
know spe saying there's only two Sexes
that's a microaggression that should get
you kicked out of your job but you know
genocide of Jews oh well you know Free
Speech both sides
right the the hypocrisy really was what
was so ging in both cases and I think
those double standards are those kinds
of double standards really endemic to
Academia um especially the ideological
ones and they're pretty they're pretty
pervasive you know you can find lots and
lots and lots and lots of cases of uh
really a very moderate not even
right-wing speech just like Centrist or
even Center left speech getting shut
down um while really radical far-left
speech including even endorsement of
terrorism it's just oh well that's
that's fine that's whatever um you know
I think that that does speak to a kind
of ideological rot in the universities
not just it's not just that the the
policies and standards are inconsistent
it's also that the fact that people just
there's a consensus that's that treats
these different speech acts um a as they
are treated and in so and in such great
disproportion to the actual content of
the speech you know I think that
suggests a kind of cultural rot at these
institutions um institutions that we
should remember are receive million
hundreds of millions a year from
taxpayers uh including you know many
taxpayers uh who have views that the
people running these universities think
are deplorable and should be should be
illegal or something so yeah you know
when you look at it that way I think
yeah like the the conservative critique
has a lot of Merit well so speaking of
taxpayers with strong opinions what role
did Bill lman play in all of
this well I mean
I obviously don't know the behind the
scenes uh calculations of the Harvard
Corporation we know not to underestimate
you and Liz for people who haven't been
following this you know day to day could
you explain who Bill Amman is
unfortunately yes uh Bill Amman is um
you know a hedge fund manager I think
his net worth is four billion he's
married to the MIT former MIT Professor
MIT scholar um and and very interesting
sort of like design scientist ner oxman
bill akman was basically as I'm I'm not
totally sure what his relationship with
the Harvard corporation which sort of
oversees the hiring and firing of cadin
gay is but it seems like I mean he's a
massive Harvard donor he got very
outspoken very riled up after the
Congressional testimonies very
dissatisfied with Gay's answers and
seems to have you know basically even
before that been exerting an awful lot
of pressure on the Harvard the Harvard
Corporation and the administrators of
Harvard to basically be treating um the
sort of Hamas sympathetic speech that
was rif on campus uh in a way that was
I'm not totally sure what he exactly
wanted to happen but it seemed like he
felt dissatisfied and angry and riled up
with the fact that students were um you
know acting as if the apartheid regime
of Israel is and I say that with air
quotes is responsible for the events of
octo October 7th um so bill akman was
sort of like very involved over the
course of October and November but it's
still I think at this point and then and
then he became very outspoken about
wanting specifically you know CAU in
Gay's head on a pike so to speak um but
it's sort of unclear what relationship
exactly he had behind the scenes with
the powers that be what do you think of
that
Erin yeah so again I I can't really I I
genuinely don't know you know what kind
of conversations may have gone on
between him and and the Harvard board
although although by by his own account
um and and everything I've seen reported
um I don't think that the Harvard board
was happy that he was going on this kind
of Twitter Crusade and I actually
suspect that it may
have he may have inadvertently prolonged
Gaye life as president of Harvard
University um because they think they
felt they felt like if they got rid of
her you know at the height of amman's
anti-gay tweet storms it
woulds sorry yeah anti claing gay to be
clear uh anti claing gay yes I I'm sure
Bill Amman um loves people of all sexual
orientations anyway um
um I I think that they probably felt
like if they if they ousted her when he
you know at the moment when he was
demanding they do it it would look
really horrible they were capitulating
to to outside pressure and donors um and
he himself tweeted that he heard that
that was one of the reasons why they
initially on December 12th I believe
affirmed their support for gay um and
did not fire
her you know in terms of the the role he
played throughout the rest of the
controversy he certainly Amplified the
plagiarism allegations on Twitter um
more people saw them so maybe that
played a role but to be honest I think
that they would have gone pretty viral
even without him and I think it sounds
like it sounds as if what really
happened was that once these plagiarism
allegations hit a critical
mass support for her really cratered
among the faculty and students too and
it just became untenable for her to lead
the university and I really don't think
Amman had very much to do with that I
not to Pat myself on the back but I
think it was largely the strength of
just the allegations and of out of my
reporting on them that made it hard for
people to uh ignore um just the SPs uh
spoke for themselves and yeah yeah and
if anything again I think that I think
that probably the collapse and support
would have happened even more quickly
had Amman not been tweeting so
aggressively because I think that those
aggressive
tweets uh
made faculty feel dug in and like they
had to defend gay against this outside
pressure but once the facts really
changed and became so sufficiently
unflattering they kind of said uh even
if we're even if in some ways we're
giving into Amman you know come on can
this person really be the president of
Harvard with the SP strikes against her
so the day after gay was fired AKA
resigned um you know depending on sort
of which narrative you want to go with
she tu teally resigned but I think it's
pretty clear that it's one of those you
need to you know pack up your things and
get out of here type conversations but
after that acman started tweeting about
Dei um this is a little bit kind of out
of left field I mean this ties into a
lot of the long-standing critiques uh
that many of us have lodged against some
of these Elite institutions but the
thing that's kind of interesting is that
I think Amman somewhat single-handedly
turned this into a Dei conversation
maybe Chris rufo was somewhat involved
in that as well uh what exactly how did
that pivot happen can we read can we
just read a little bit of his uh very
long Twitter post please don't read the
whole thing he says you know in in light
of today's news I thought today's news
being Claud and Di Gay's uh resignation
I thought I would try to take a step
back and provide perspective on what
this is really all about uh and
scrolling down past a lot of this uh I
ultimately concluded that anti-Semitism
was not the core of the problem it was
simply a troubling warning sign it was
the quote Canary in the coal mine I came
to learn that the root cause of
anti-Semitism at Harvard was an ideology
that has been promulgated on campus an
oppressor oppressed framework that
provided the intellectual bull workk
behind the protests then I did more
research the more I learned the more
concerned I became and the more ignorant
I realized I had been about
Dei yeah this whole thing kind of
annoyed me because a Dei like we can
talk about the oppressor oppressed sort
of social justice framework but Dei is
almost sort of the more recent
incarnation of that right like Dei sort
of more frequently applies to admissions
practices and hiring practices um it's
okay I guess if we want to expand that
term to sort of be the Umbrella by which
we talk about these other ideologies
that have been rampant on campus but
it's a little bit weird and then the
other thing that annoys me about this is
it's just like were you born yesterday
Bill Amman right like this has been
going on for I mean I entered College in
2014 and I left in 2016 I think in 2013
2014 that was sort of the beginning of
this most recent round of Campus speech
craziness and absurd double standards
but I'm a little bit like well Bill
Amman you've been donating to Harvard
for an awful long time and you sort of
weren't like who was minding the store
who was keeping watch clearly not you
what do you think
eron yeah I had I had largely the same
reaction uh especially not not so much
to Amman but to
um Mark Rowan and some of these other
donors uh who fermented the revolt
against pen I was like oh now you
realize that they're all terrorists and
they're crazy okay great well we've been
telling you that for decades and now you
figure it out all right like uh little
belated um I will say in amman's
particular defense that he has gone
beyond just saying wait anti-Semitism is
a problem on campus and some of the
activists are a little crazy to seeming
to really Embrace a pretty thoroughgoing
critique of the entire Dei regime and
yes Dei is a recent incarnation of it
but I I think when you look at his posts
he seems to understand oh wait there's
kind of systemic race discrimination at
universities um and basically anyone who
uh you know anyone who's not a straight
white male can claim victim status and
use that status to uh to gain special
privileges and suppress any kind of
speech that they deem offensive or
harmful huh that seems bad you know he's
actually he seems to understand now the
nature of the problem um and I think
that's a good thing um and he seems to
have understood it better than some
other yeah yeah well I want to ask you
about the nature of the problem that
he's outlining there which what what
he's saying and this is something I've
heard this is an argument I've heard a
lot lately that the anti-Semitism that
has been expressed in these anti-israel
or Pro Palestine movements is a natural
outgrowth of Dei this is where Dei leads
to
anti-Semitism um is there anything to
that in your estimation is that a sound
argument yeah I think it's a very sound
argument I mean let me try to try to put
it in the clearest way possible think
about okay think about what a lot of Dei
rhetoric focuses on it focuses on
disparities between groups and the
premise is always that any disparities
are caused by oppression um of some sort
uh you know any any kind of innocuous
explanation for the disparity certainly
any explanation that just says well you
know one group just happens to like be
you know better at rising to the top of
this field that's certainly not allowed
right um well look that creates a bit of
a problem because in case you haven't
noticed Jews are over represented in a
lot of fields um they're over
represented they are over represented in
finance they are in fact over
represented in hollyood would and
although they're less over represented
on Ivy League campuses than they used to
be for various reasons we can maybe get
into they are still over represented on
IV League campuses they're not over
represented on sports teams correct
they're not um and yet no one and yet no
one thinks that that is a reflection of
systemic anti-jewish Prejudice um on the
part of the NBA uh so for some reason no
one's made that argument but uh but look
uh if if you think that all disparities
especially just arities that that that
favor white coded individuals like Jews
are ipsofacto illegitimate and and
racist well
uh then it looks like that then we have
a problem because Jews are in fact over
represented in a lot of fields and and
uh by the logic of Dei that should
suggest that they have kind of unearned
privilege at that's the
most in uous formulation and the least
inous formation is they they have their
privileges as a of a kind of
illegitimate almost conspiracy or or or
system of power that that keeps others
down um and it's not hard to see how
that's going to just turn into sort of
bfashion Jews control everything they're
evil anti-Semitism um that really is the
is the causal pathway from Dei to
anti-Semitism now now there's another
dimension here too which I think is
related but separate which is just that
in practice this Dei proponents wouldn't
say this out loud but I think this is
this is implicit in a lot of the
rhetoric there's just kind of a
knee-jerk assumption o kind of white
people have unearned privilege and tend
to be the bad guys um and white people
can't be victims and most Jews in
America are white now some Jews would
say oh I'm not really white blah blah
blah but in practice most of of them are
classified as white by the census they
look white and in the social
construction of race that is currently
operative in the United States Jews are
white um so but when you've said that
all white people are part of this you
know system of power that that that
makes them
oppressors then the very idea that Jews
who are a subset of whites could be
victims just becomes much more harder to
to cogniz um and I think that's the
other big part of the story right this
is this is as much a lot of the
anti-Semitism I think here is is made
it's not necessarily caused by but it's
it's made possible by a kind of
anti phrase might get me in trouble but
a kind of anti-white cultural default
where whites are just assumed to be in
power and kind of bad in some way
right when that is the cultural default
at these institutions it becomes harder
to talk about subsets of white people
who may be victimized in various ways or
at least for whom that Assumption of
power uh and privilege may be a little
more complicated um so I do think de EI
and kind of broader Notions of
progressive
identitarianism do have a lot to do with
anti-Semitism um I would I would just
say that you know having made that
argument you know it is important to
distinguish between harsh criticism of
Israel and anti-Semitism right those are
not necessarily the same thing and just
because progressivism makes people focus
more on the settlements or whatever like
that's not intrinsically antiemetic with
the anti- whiteness argument that you
laid out which I think is broadly true
um you know that that is how a lot of
these Progressive activists see it how
did it get bastardized and get away from
like Coleman Hughes has made this
argument I've made this argument many
times I think many people of our ilk um
sort of believe this type of thing where
it's like well if progressives actually
care about uplifting the marginalized
right like trying to apply the
ideological Turin test and really
believe um you know
fully approaching their argument in
totally good faith if they're interested
in uplifting the marginalized why aren't
they doing a class-based critique right
under which you know poor rust Bel
whites would be seen as extremely
marginalized right and a a wealthy Jew
who's had every advantage in life who
grew up in the Northeast and was sent to
the best schools you know really has an
awful lot of privilege afforded to them
right like why is it that it became this
whiteness uh as the demonized thing and
you know anybody who's white passing
sort of gets mapped on to that as
opposed to the much richer understanding
of this I think which would be a
class-based one which I'm sure would
still end up in places where I as a
Libertarian disagree but would at least
feel intellectually rigorous and
sound well there's lots of reasons and
obviously we can't do a deep dive into
the the intellectual genealogy of of
wokeness right that that's beyond the
scope of this conversation but I think
there is also a very kind of obvious
material reason uh to be a little
Marxist about it which is just uh who
provides the donations to these schools
it's rich people and so if you did the
class-based
thing right you know
the the kid from the rust Bel would
frankly offer is is I think more pressed
the the poor rust Bel
Evangelical is much less privileged than
a wealthy Jew from Manhattan um and
would add far more meaningful diversity
to Harvard or Yale than that Jewish
student would um but the Jewish students
parents uh frankly are more likely to
donate a wing uh of you know to the
library or or or a new cancer center
right I mean it's just true so I think
that is a big part of it that's also one
reason why a lot of
the you know minorities who are admitted
especially there a lot of
African-Americans who get into these
schools who in some cases they're not
African-American they're just African
right and their parents are wealthy
immigrants from African countries or you
know they maybe are are yes they're
black kids but they they went to Andover
exiter right uh they didn't grow up in
Anacostia um and that's I think in part
because look it's just expensive to if
your affirmative action program was
class-based uh the university would have
less money than if it were than if it's
race based um so I don't think that's
the only reason but I do think that that
is a big part of it um yeah well when
did you um I want to shift to what got
you so initially um frustrated by
wokeness which I think has sort of to
some degree like powered a lot of your
career right you do this really
interesting sort of shoe weather
reporting um and you have a lot of
people you get a lot of Scoops you have
a lot of people leaking stuff to you and
you've done a really really solid job of
uncovering a lot of the deep ideological
rot in these institutions did you what
year did you enter Yale 2014 2014 so
actually I think Liz we're the we're the
same age although you gra graduated
before I did um but uh so I was there
2014 to 2018 um and so while while I was
there the the famous Halloween costume
controversy took place where C of that
really fast of the yeah I've I've pulled
that clip actually because I want you to
reflect on how this uh informed your
your world view um and you can talk
about what was going on with you at the
time other people have rights too not
just hold on let me set this up a little
bit more Adam uh this is um the the
Halloween costume controversy was that a
letter uh had gone out um uh suggesting
you know us um suggesting culturally
sensitive Halloween costumes and some of
the faculty had objected to the idea
that administrators would uh tell uh
college students who are adults what is
appropriate to wear for Halloween um and
one of those people was uh Erica
christakis whose husband Nicholas Chris
stakus uh was uh sort of a dean of
Housing and he was confronted by a bunch
of angry students who thought that
administrators should dictate or you
know set some parameters for what is and
isn't a Halloween costume and this is a
clip from that confrontation provided by
uh fire uh the uh free campus Free
Speech group so let's uh play that clip
walk away walk away
quiet for all you understand that as
your position as matter it is your job
to create a place of comfort and home
for the students that live in silan you
have not done that by sending out that
email that goes against your position as
Master do you understand that I don't
agree with that then then why the [__]
did you accept the position who the [__]
hired you have a different Vision you
should step down if that is what you
think about being a you should step
down uh how did so you so you were you
were on campus when all that drama
unfolded uh how did that not
only Not only was I on campus but a I
actually saw a part of that interaction
unfold from across the street because I
lived in the Residential College across
the street from sullon uh and B I was
the opinion editor of the Yale Daily
News which meant that
I uh not only had to solicit and edit op
EDS from Angry students uh upset about
all the systemic racism allegedly
permeating Yale but I also had to write
the paper's official
editorial uh about the protests and the
way the editorial process worked was
that it was basically just a democratic
vote by the the editorial board um and
then the opinion editor had to kind of
execute the will of the editorial board
and write the the the oped even if the
opinion editor didn't agree with the
will of the editorial board and as
happened in this case right um you know
I'm not actually sure it was
meaningfully a democratic vote because
we got into the meeting to discuss
things and it it became clear within
seconds that anyone who dissented was
going to get called racist and shouted
down so nobody did even though I think a
lot of people privately
thought this was going too far they
didn't say anything you didn't
either it was it was very clear that
like if I had TR I sort of I tried to
gently push back on some things but it
was quite clear that had I pushed it too
far it would have just devolved and the
outcome would have been the same but
even worse uh and so I kind of made a
tactical decision all right like you
know I'm not going to win this fight so
the best I can do is sort of try to
moderate whatever we end up writing um
so I had to actually write a fawning
editorial saying oh my God these
protesters are so brave and you know why
does the University you know should
listen to their pain blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah and then when I tried to
even sneak in a line about Free Speech
uh what happened was it was being there
was like a Google doc that was that was
effectively being uh stealth not stealth
edited But like everyone was looking at
the Google Doc so then I throw in the
line and people come over to me and say
I think this sounds you know like you're
blaming the protesters how could you and
then that line gets taken out so it was
it was a [__] show it was terrible just
sitting at a keyboard just sweating
right you know carefully writing these
sentences is if people are watching the
Google dock that's pretty I'm not joking
that is what happened and uh look it was
it was it was a preview of what happened
to the New York Times and other big
media outlets in 20 media Outlets that
of course employ a lot of alums of the
Daily News and the Harvard crimson and
other such did this radicalize you this
is the origin story I I you know
radicalize is a bit of a strong word
because I it's not like it's not like I
was a normal I mean I was kind of a
moderate Democrat who was just pro- Free
Speech but but you know it's not like I
was went from moderate Democrat to you
know fire breathing Maga or anything
like that but yeah it it it made me much
more concerned about who the Future
Leaders of the country would be um I it
definitely pushed me right and
subsequent developments after college
further pushed me right um but yeah this
was sort of a inflection point maybe
maybe radicalization is too strong but
certainly an inflection point in my
political trajectory well so I came to
college in 2014 same time as you and I
think for me the environment there was
extraordinarily radicalizing to the
point that it even inspired me one could
say to graduate early which was not my
plan to do so because I just had a
miserable time on campus I went to the
College of William and Mary and to set
the stage for um old geezers like Zach
and uh our viewers and listeners who
might not know you know 2014 was a weird
time it was right after um I guess the
officer who had uh stood accused of
killing Michael Brown had been acquitted
there were all of these riots related to
Ferguson Ferguson was basically on fire
sort of a precursor to the George Floyd
summer 2020 protest obviously we've seen
these um bubbling UPS of the protest
movement surrounding cop killings and
police brutality in the United States
this was not the first incarnation of it
uh and it was also not the last one but
2013 2014 was a very hot time for that
type of thing and so I recall that fall
being really intense on campus for that
reason for all of the racial and police
brutality reasons and then Rolling Stone
published the now widely discredited a
rape on campus um rape H story that
basically describes and I think this was
talked about at many college campuses
you know I went to William and Mary and
obviously this had occurred on uva's
campus uh very very close by you know
lots of friends there and so I think it
made a huge Splash not just in that sort
of college microcosm but on other
campuses too because there was
essentially I think a little bit of this
precursor to me too happening where you
know suddenly these sort of twin issues
of race relations police brutality and
campus sexual assault and sexual
harassment were sort of not exactly
entering the public Consciousness but
certainly having this huge moment and to
be 18 years old and to have these two
issues where so many people were saying
hey you're either with us or you're
against us you're either fired up about
this or you're you know an evil you know
Trump tar didn't exist yet but like an
evil right-winger um it very much made
it so I think many people were
were I don't want to say forced into
submission but very much given all of
the social incentives to believe what
the herd believes to go with the herd
yes and to not their descent and I was
one of the people I was writing for my
college newspaper and descenting from
this and a lot of activists really made
my life hell as a result it ended up
becoming very quickly apparent it was
made apparent quite quickly to me that
this would not actually be a healthy
thriving place of intellectual discourse
and I should just cut my losses and get
the hell out because being part of the
working world is so much better uh you
know being an actual journalist to be
able to engage more thoughtfully with
these things agree but did you have a
similar experience like were you doing
the exact same thing that I was just a
little bit
north yeah it was it was similar um I
one time when I was the opinion editor
of the paper I published a oped
criticizing migration to Europe which
was admittedly I think
a defensible but also pretty fire and
brimstone restrictionist take um on the
issue um but you know we published crazy
farle things all the time uh that were
just
completely completely batshit so I
thought all right you know this is a
little over the top in the other
direction but that's fine you know he's
not calling for genocide or anything
like it's he's just saying that Europe
should stop accepting migrants because
they're destroying like the culture of
Europe and creating safety issues okay
it's a little much but you know he can
say that I published it and then a girl
came up to me in the coffee shop like in
public and started berating me for
publishing the opet um and and to be
honest I didn't care that much because
like what was this girl going to do to
me but but that that I think gives you a
sense of what the climate was like um I
was lucky that I Gale had a good network
of conservative student groups
especially this
political union which contains a lot of
conservative political parties and so I
I was in one of those and I kind of had
a friend group that I knew was not going
to cancel me or disown me um and in fact
within that friend group I was like the
token lib um so if anything they were
like they'd be like Aaron you know okay
yeah it's nice that you believe in free
speech but really what you should
believe is that we need a Catholic
Monarch who will suppress free speech in
the interest of creating you know Our
Lady of Guadalupe Empire from from North
America to South America or whatever
like like it it sounds it sounds like a
joke but there were actually people who
believe that um so you know they they
all for me they were like oh yeah you
know you you you think that maybe uh
maybe Title 9 is going a little too far
right like oh you know you think you're
controversial well wait till you hear
what we believe um so how are they
treated on campus though like like
you're saying there were people way Weir
you well because they had the social
group like they were fine they also
weren't as outspoken though like they
weren't writing their CES committing
them to paper I think people probably
knew that they were catholic and
conservative but they they
typically I think were pretty good about
just just knowing when and where to to
share that so yeah look I I I had a
similar experience although I would say
that I didn't feel as socially isolated
as I think some people felt and I
actually especially at Yale where there
is this kind of conservative
infrastructure you know I would probably
advise students to be a little less
afraid of getting cancelled because as
long as you have the friends who won't
cancel you like doesn't really matter if
someone calls you a mean name on
Facebook it just should learn to get
over that um but yeah look these these
these universities often do have a very
stifling climate for for free speech and
I do know people at other uh Elite
schools um where there was not I think
as healthy a network of dissident
students and at those schools people who
spoke out
really re you know based of a steep
social price um yeah no it's it's a it's
problem um and so and and you asked
earlier do I think there's anything to
the conservative critique well having
seen it up close I mean yeah you know
the you you really will see kids get
piled on for saying things that are if
anything way to the left of Fox News but
just not quite to the left of Bernie
Sanders and you know you don't see
anything like that Pyon um triggered by
students saying that rationality is a
tool of white male oppression which
someone literally wrote almost exactly
that in an oped for me that I had to
edit right I was sitting next to the
girl and editing it with her line by
line and the thesis of the oped was that
demands for rational discourse are a way
of policing the emotionality of women of
color
right like it's pretty crazy and you
know that was what you were expected to
say oh that's an important perspective
thank you so much for writing this offet
like no I mean come
on and I think that kind of stifling
environment uh it sewed a lot of seeds
of of discontent that perhaps are coming
to fruition now uh in the form of a
significant backlash and um this it's
something that Claudine gay alluded to
in her response to all this she
published an oped in the New York Times
um and uh you know saying that what
happened at Harvard is bigger than me
and she identified two two themes here
uh one is she said that the campaign
against me was about more than one
University and one leader this was
merely a single Skirmish in a broader
War to unravel public faith in Pillars
of American society trusted ins tions of
all types from public health agencies to
news organizations will continue to fall
victim to coordinated attempts to
undermine their legitimacy and ruin
their leaders uh credibility uh and then
she goes on to say that this uh was
largely an attack on her because she was
a black woman selected to lead a stored
institution I think we can kind of put
aside that that second one we've kind of
gone through a lot of the evidence as to
why claudian gay was forced to resign um
but to that that first critique um where
it's a very much like I I am this fouchy
I am the science kind of moment I am
Academia this is an attack on our
hallowed institutions themselves um part
of the that that line of argumentation
comes from the actions of people like
Chris rufo who was also involved in this
story and who characteristically just
like diabolically announced
this in a tweet we he says we launched
the Claudine gay plagiarism story from
the right the next step is to smuggle it
into the media apparatus from the of the
left legitimizing the narrative to
Center left actors who have the power to
topple her then
squeeze um he also announced that he'd
gotten a scalp when Claudine gay was
fired which like okay fair but also
according according to the Associated
Press that that was very racist with fil
oh yeah that is a Indians that was a
practice that was a practice of white
colonizers who scalped Native Americans
um and also sometimes Native Americans
scalped scalped other people but that's
that's just an aside yeah you have to
Native Americans were never barbaric
they always did everything according to
the moral standards of 2024 you know
like come on correct they never did any
raping or pillaging look I I I I don't
begrudge Chris rufo publishing this
material what whatever his motivations
are I I'm always happy to get uh true
material about uh you know uh important
public figures uh and it's more
important to evaluate the source
material rather than the conduit who
published it but I I do have to say I
find his allout Warfare mindset to be
pretty cynical and unsettling because
you're kind of eroding the Norms of
discourse and justifying it with like
well the other side is Ed these SLE
tactics to take down their enemies so
it's fair game to to do the same and
like doesn't doesn't the roffo mentality
kind of create a ratchet effect and just
leave us with these two horrible
unprincipled Waring sides crowding out
any rational discourse yeah I mean I
think that is a possibility to to defend
rufo I'm not necessarily saying I agree
with this but but I think the defense
would be look if we want their be
healthy Norms of
discourse there has to be an incentive
to adopt the healthier Norms of
discourse and for a long time I think it
is true there really was an asymmetry in
terms of the blowback that would be
faced by people on different sides of
the political
spectrum and and one theory is that if
you ratchet up the pressure on the left
right um and do to the left what's been
done to the right maybe that will cause
the left to evolve
re-evolve kind of better Free Speech
Norms much like the ACLU did in the 50s
and 60s right the ACLU used to be a
Communist front group and then
discovered that Free Speech was actually
very beneficial to uh protecting
communist speech and then and I think
genuinely came to believe in free speech
for many decades but there was a kind of
self-interested partisan incentive for
them to believe in it um when the
incentive structure was different so not
crazy to think that going after the left
in this way can in fact
serve the interests of better discursive
Free Speech
Norms but I also think that that
argument rests on a lot of assumptions
about how incentives will be understood
and processed and internalized by the
various actors that that are not
self-evident and I think there is a real
chance that it does devolve into what
you're saying where it's just yeah total
tribalism and and everything just gets
worse and worse
um you
know the other thing I would say though
about this could I just say one more
thing is is please do someone so so I
was on another podcast and and my friend
deir maruch made the point that you
know when when when Bor was held up in
that confirmation battle um Supreme
Court it it kind of marked
a a real shift in Norms around Supreme
Court confirmation fights that we've
arguably never recovered from and now
there's just a lot more partisanship on
both sides you have Mitch McConnell
saying we're not gonna you know we're
not gonna uh just consider anyone tough
luck until the next election and then
you have um the the the attempts to
destroy Brett Cavanaugh and and things
like that it just that is a case where
it just seems like it was a ration
effect everything got worse and worse
and worse time and so one way you could
look at that is to say either you could
start it with Garland and you know
refusal to confirm Meritt Garland was
really where it started you could go
back to Bor and say well that's really
where it started the evil
Democrats but another way you could look
at it is to say listen why was there a
fight over the Supreme Court in the
first place why did why were the stakes
such that people felt these tactics even
needed to be deployed on either side
well um in the 1970s the Supreme Court
AR to itself the right to determine when
life and human rights begin and just
said by the way um yeah uh until
trimester until the end of the second
trimester uh no no no rights whatsoever
women can do what they want and there's
not we're not going to vote on this
we're not even going to try to really
rigorously justify it with the
contitution we're just going to come up
with this BS argument that even rbj
would later say was
crazy and that that I think really
changed things as the Supreme Court just
arrogated more power to itself it became
more and more important who controlled
the Supreme Court and both sides had an
incentive to pull out all the stops to
to control it um and I think you can
argue that something similar is
happening with universities and and so I
think it's a bit of a mistake to lay all
the blame at rufo's feet or or really
anyone's feet it's like what happened
over the past few years universities
became more important college degrees
became more important to
um employment prospects
universities uh developed got larger
endowments they wormed their ways into
more and more aspects of elite policy
making the distinction I mean
universities were involved in all the
you know they set up these
misinformation centers that were
involved in attempts to regulate
Facebook and Google and all and Twitter
the distinction between the officially
private universities and the government
really has
has eroded so these institutions part of
why there's such a culture War battle is
that they're just more important and
powerful than they've ever been and if
you don't want this kind of the this
waron expertise that Claud and gay is
talking about well maybe those
institutions need to be a little more
humble and stop arrogating crazy
dictatorial powers to themselves you
know she says Public Health agencies huh
I wonder why there's a culture War over
the public health agencies you know was
there anything recently where maybe they
um kind of said by the way you should
shut down the entire economy and you
can't go outside of your homes oh except
to protest black lives matter that's
fine might that have had something to do
with the attacks on them I don't know
but like maybe there's a deeper problem
here with the hubris of elite
institutions that has set this in motion
and you can deplore Chris rufo's tactics
all you want but they are I think kind
of like people say oh you know terrorism
it's just kind of an inevitable response
like it's
like some of this stuff is just an
inevitable response to material to
material conditions on the ground
changing and it doesn't make it good or
excusable I'm not saying you should
support or not what Chris Roo is doing
but someone like him was going to come
along and do this no matter what
eventually and I think universities
frankly do bear a lot of the blame for
that I I hear you and I think we're on
the same page in terms of the course
correction that needs to happen in terms
of you know checking the huis a little
bit and you know decentralizing power
certainly in the case of Public Health
agencies um as we uh bring this home
Erin I I got to ask though like are you
optimistic that this is a course
correction in effect or is this kind of
just a temporary blip do you have any
thoughts overall you know actually
crumbling I vacillate a little on this I
I think yeah I do think that now that
you see people like Amman tweeting about
Dei and musk and some of these
billionaires that does suggest to me
that there could be a
real not that it not that we're going to
see it the pendulum swing super far in
the other direction and the country is
going to suddenly be super right-wing
anti- Dei but I but I think that you
will see more organized opposition to it
um more organized opposition to it which
may blunt some of its excesses and and
allow kind of a base of operations for
further attempts to systematically
dismantle the Dei regime um and I think
that is frankly a good thing um that
people are there's sort of been an
Awakening of political Consciousness
among people who matter that oh wait
there is this Dei thing and it's bad and
it permeates every aspect of Our Lives
huh I'm sitting on4 billion dollar maybe
I should do something about that like
that's that's not a bad development um I
would say that I think
a lot of the kind of deep kind of
conceptual underpinnings of Dei
especially the assumptions about
disparities and what is and is not a
legitimate explanation for them I think
that stuff frankly long predates Dei and
is now very very deeply ingrained in
much of elite and even not so Elite
culture and
so you know
I I I don't I don't think people should
prematurely declare Victory um a lot of
a lot of the fights that we're currently
having were already had in the 1970s
with say busing or other things in just
a slightly different form so I suspect a
lot of these culture War battles will
continue to be fixtures of our politics
and won't have a clear resolution but I
do think that whereas before it was kind
of like this you know Army of well
funded leftists who just were dictating
priorities to
institutions in 2020 and the immediate
years after now they're going to face a
lot more push back and you know it'll be
a bit more of a fair fight and hopefully
that results in a negotiated settlement
that we can all live with um As
Americans two- State solution if you
will yeah a two State yeah exactly yeah
that that that's an optimistic peaceful
uh peace optimistically peaceful way to
uh leave it uh Aon sarum thank you for
your your work on the topic and for
joining us to talk through it
today thank you so much for having me
this is
great thanks for listening to just
asking questions these conversations
appear on reason's YouTube channel and
Facebook page every Thursday and the
just asking questions podcast feed every
Friday subscribe wherever you get your
podcasts and please rate and review the
show